le voilà
le temps des fêtes c'est l'occasion de
célébrer avec les gens qui nous sont
chères et de partager de bons moments
c'est le spectacle ça devient une
nouvelle tradition du temps des fêtes
pour nous puis maintenant ça fait partie
de notre nos routines et nos traditions
familiales
le spectacle réunit sur scène et en
coulisse trois générations qui partagent
l'amour de la musique et de l'humour
c'est touchant chanter avec ses fils
dans quelques secondes je préparais à
quel point je suis fier même
au rabais on allait et fierté et un
bonheur partagé par yvon de choc
assister au premier concert ce moment où
on essaie de créer un peu de magie mais
c'est aussi le fait qu'on voit est en
jeu sauf en 2020 mais normalement on est
ensemble une seule chose de très
important les spectacles noël chez les
deschamps mélange anecdotes du temps des
fêtes chansons originales airs
classiques de noël le temps d'un concert
on a l'impression de faire partie de
leur famille ok green chan aux arrêts
pour différentes raisons à différentes
époques mais les mêmes chansons de noël
nous met le même sort et un
noël c'est aussi l'occasion de penser
aux plus démunis d'ailleurs le concert
du 14 décembre sera au bénéfice de la
fondation yvon deschamps centre-sud car
il faut savoir revenir à l'essentiel
quand on a vu que c'était là un petit
peu trop de surconsommation puis en tout
cas moi j'ai parlé à mes enfants je leur
ai demandé de ce qu'est ce qu'ils
voulaient vraiment pour noël c'était en
fait à être ensemble chaque geste
en effet il espère qu'en plus d'un noël
blanc nous auront droit cette année un
noël vers la planète et pas mal ah non
mais nous on est en danger est en grand
danger
faudrait que quelqu'un trouve une façon
de bien communiquer ça on va l'appeler
n'était pas malade mais nous risquons
nos vies
en plus du disque jeudi six filles
partiront pour une tournée de six dates
dans la grande région de montréal neil
chez les deschamps c'est l'occasion de
faire des voeux de se plonger dans
l'ambiance des fêtes une invitation à
partager amour et bonté
ici nabi alexandre chartier radio-canada
mourir
[Musique]
c
tu
[Musique]